hello and welcome to the video I'm
joined by my housemate Dan and our
friend Lily who you have met before Lily
because she's a girl and society has
really not clear gender expectations
knows about makeup or just intro and you
yeah I'm done I do not because we are
man yeah buh-burn manly man muscle in
men I've ever met and we thought we'd
get Lily to do our makeup for us let's
let's do this oh you think you have a
big moment have to change your batteries
when we do the forehead
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Lily's just poking me in the drag race
is famous for need to tell me soon look
you one side you want daytime flirty or
do you want no just like nighttime
thanks I'm gonna document okay so then I
go before powder yeah it's pretty
natural it's pretty true to what your
brow is you're on dangerous ground there
down what do you wish Lily that people
knew about makeup do you think they
don't know like from a gender
perspective
we just it's just fun it's just a good
bit of fun and it doesn't have to mean
anything more than it it did because
like like people read into it so much
like oh you know take girls swimming on
the Thursday like it's just a fun thing
to do it if it gives girls confident
like back off like for me when I was a
teenager I hated like the idea of makeup
because I was so like anything
associated with kind of femininity and
being feminine I rejected because it was
also associated with being weaker or bad
and all that kind of stuff
and I wanted to be a cool kid who like
threw myself in the mud I realized those
two things weren't mutually exclusive
hmm so now I am I very much roll around
in the mud and I look fabulous while
you're doing we've been missing out then
we should have been doing this all along
[Laughter]
is when I do the weird
Mary Mary berry can you come on in my
creams but basically you just get kind
of like the whitest power you can get
and you can use tapenade which is why
use so yeah this is also one of those
things I approach away at the end but
it's called baking because you you brush
your in powder once it's come to your
body temperature I don't know why but
you just brush it away at the end of it
it's like that's kind of this is really
a my help
[Laughter]
you're behind a wall how did I'm really
curious to what you would like okay my
turn
this is very relaxing yeah you say that
so now well that's just kind of drive a
little bit you wanna tell me what would
you like I was thinking wow I'm really
engaging with is something like smoky
like dark I mean I can do that and then
maybe something of its peers okay a
night out kind of look I thought that's
what my viewers are gonna wanna see so
let's give the people what they want
oh geez I see this big coming of my
heart
pretty me i shy i can't shave more
recently did you go against the grain
yes no but I didn't bits
you're not supposed to and causes
ingrown hairs seek met beauty tips are
just limited to women
what our unit makeup oh it was told once
that like the majority of male youtubers
do wear some makeup yeah basically you
stop it no because to prevent the shine
from lights yeah I'm always surprised
that you don't wear a little bit of
powder just I mean I'll be honest
partners the fact that I feel it because
I'm a guy I shouldn't which I know is a
very silly thing to think thing is like
I certainly get that looks like why as a
teenager I didn't you don't apply into
the classic gender normative roles for
showbiz it serves a purpose I've seen
when are you gonna get a palette knife
out sorry can you just to show you again
what you wanted me to do I'm just I just
panicked to give you a random facial
[Laughter]
expressions about it your eye makeup and
then I'm gonna do a winged liner to
bring it all together and then a lot of
mascara right much more than 10 boxes a
little bit ok ok ok have more faith in
me than I am still here you understand
oh my god a fierce yeah you know normal
and you're just gonna even a blank okay
oh you go oh my god I would kill for
lashes so damn always a question earlier
that I just didn't want to wait for the
amount of time that you've been
putting makeup on Sunday night
individually how long could you achieve
the same effect on yourself well what
you did to your face I could probably do
to my own in about 25 minutes I'm gonna
how long I spend on yours still call a
lot of time yeah on a daily look yeah I
could probably do it in 15 minutes 20
minutes in a hurry yeah but I don't tend
to do that because right each other
we're gonna reveal in 3 2 1 your eyes
I'm still not I'm still adjusting to
this I'll be honest
yeah like attractive actually just as
you looked went amazing her different
your eyes do you think you might do it
again I don't think I'll do it quite
like this again yeah I can't help a
[Laughter]
[Music]
little bit like I guess it's like a
power up to your sensuality like yeah I
feel more confident I think really has
been really interesting
the psychological effect yeah I don't
think it does go to show that you don't
have to do makeup like this necessarily
like men can do parts of this if it
makes them you know I mean as I keep
saying eye makeup is just fun like this
was just a bit of fun like on the
evening because it was stabbing down in
the eye but I can understand now that
people might want to wear it to make
them feel more empowered and make me
feel more confident I don't think I have
a I kind of like I guess I knew it I
didn't understand it yeah I feel like
experiencing it is different it's also
it does show you like how much goes into
it well thank you very much want to see
a full barely cut version of this we're
gonna put that on a second channel
spongy and electric which is Dan a nice
little some partner project I guess we
put we put other kinds of things like
this a heck of a lot of fun you should
join us and you can follow all of us on
Twitter links down the do you have to
thank you yeah so anything interesting
week follow me anyway tell you Daniel J
more at Simon rocks fears I have no idea
thank you very much for watching
everybody
hey nice time
[Music]
you